A generation ago, in one of the most popular shows on TV, Cosmos, the host
Carl Sagan began each episode by saying that Cosmos is all that is, or was, or
ever will be.
In a nutshell, Carl Sagan was describing the worldview known as naturalism, which is
the view that all that exists is the physical, material world, and in which there is
no supernatural realm.
Naturalism is clearly the predominant worldview in Western culture, shaping
institutions like the educational system, the university, and even the media.
Naturalism offers non-supernatural answers to our four big worldview questions.
First, what is real? According to naturalism, the only things that are real are
those that can be tested by the five senses.
In other words, only those things that have height, weight, extension in space,
and other physical properties.
So essentially, if something can't be weighed on a scale, or seen through a
microscope, it doesn't exist. So things like God, values, purposes,
objective morality, demons, and the soul are not real.
But of course, things like grass, water, and sand are real.
So, what is man?
On naturalism, man is not the purposeful creation intended by a loving God
meant to be in relationship with God and with other people.
In fact, the late atheist Victor Stenger captured the naturalistic view of man well.
Darwinism implies that humanity developed by accident, contradicting the traditional
teaching that humans are special, created in God's image.
So essentially, that means that you and me and all of creation is a cosmic accident.
Now the third question is, what happens at death?
There are really three options of what happens to you when you die.
One would be to face some kind of judgment and go to either heaven or hell.
The other possibility is to go through some kind of cycle of reincarnation.
And the last possibility is extinction.
That when you die, you cease to exist.
Now on the naturalistic worldview, since there's no God and there's no soul, when
you stop breathing your last breath, your life is done.
Death is final. In the 1970s, the band Kansas had a
famous song in which they described human beings as merely dust in the wind.
That all our dreams are a mere curiosity.
So we're like a drop of water in an endless sea.
All that lasts forever is the earth below and the sky above.
So then our fourth question is, what is the basis for right and wrong?
Since naturalists don't believe in God, there's no standard outside of mankind that
determines right and wrong. Well there are a variety of different attempts to
explain morality from the naturalistic worldview.
Essentially, it boils down to what benefits mankind and helps propagate the species.
Naturalism is nothing new. In fact, centuries before the time of Christ, there were
some Greek philosophers who believed that all reality could be described as these
small, tiny atoms. While naturalism may not be new, it is in direct
contrast and conflict with the Christian worldview.
The question is, can it capture reality, both as we experience it and know it to
be?